[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5 monde et vos chaînes
locales de la tnt tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité bien fait et
périls du tourisme dit on en bretagne et
en occitanie au début de ce journal pour
découvrir deux rapports au tourisme très
différent avec les chaînes tv haut et
via occitanie quand certains cherchent à
protéger leur territoire d'autres
tentent d'attirer plus de vacanciers la
tendance survivalisme aussi à découvrir
dans cette édition vosges télévision a
pu suivre un stage d'un week-end
organisé en pleine forêt bain de boue et
pompes au programme vous le verrez et
rencontres dans cette édition avec denis
dupuy auteur et écrivain il vient de
sortir un nouveau roman où l'on suit les
aventures du docteur 33,1 docteur
toulousain à la vie tourmentée et
philosophiques
on commence ce journal avec toujours le
même dilemme pour les zones touristiques
pendant les grandes vacances comment
attirer des visiteurs développer
l'économie locale et en même temps
préserver son territoire la presqu'île
de crozon sur la pointe bretonne fait
partie des terrains prisée des touristes
mais l'afflux de visiteurs créé
d'importants problèmes de circulation
notamment pour les riverains comme l'a
constaté sur place louis floch pour
tébéo et tv sud les chaînes locales de
couple télégramme sur place
al'approche de la saison estivale la
presqu'île de crozon se prépare à
accueillir ces touristes les nombreuses
plages du littoral attirer les
passionnés de glisse à lapalud seulement
vingt habitants vivent à l'année alors
dans ces rues très étroites en pleine
saison l'atmosphère est parfois tendues
je crois que les surfeurs commencent à
prendre conscience qu'on en a ras-le-bol
de cette circulation et donc ils font
attention un des problèmes de
circulation sur les routes mais aussi
sur les sentiers de randonnée les
randonneurs sont aussi très nombreux
rallyes la presqu'île l'an passé ils
étaient soixante mille à fouler le gr34
cette habituée ressent clairement les
conséquences de la sur fréquentation
ah oui moi j'ai vu une dégradation du
sentier là vers l'île vierge qui est
impressionnant le bois aussi et j'ai
même remarqué j'avais admiré un pas
maritime qui était près d'un banc qui
quatre ans après il détruit durant l'été
la population de la presqu'île est
multiplié par quatre face à cet afflux
la mairie de crozon et son maire patrick
berthelot s'organisent pour permettre
l'accueil des visiteurs nous avons
longue absence de projet à deux
d'organisation de 2,6 nadia tic qui ce
qui ne fonctionnera que les paies pas
l'hiver faire on a plein dessus plein de
projets qui vont permettre de fluidifier
de permettre la proche des commerces de
faire vivre le centre bourg
l'accès aux plages étaient en fait tout
tout tout est lié un parking de camping
car est actuellement aux constructions
en amont de la ville les nouvelles
mesures de la mairie interviendront dans
quelques semaines voilà et contrairement
à la presqu'île de crozon qui essaie de
limiter l'impact du tourisme d'autres
communes elle tente de les attirer pour
y parvenir ces collectivités n'hésitent
plus à faire appel à ce qu'on appelle
des influenceurs c'est le cas par
exemple de l'office de tourisme de
beaucaire terre d'argence près de nîmes
objectif séduire les followers de ses
stars des réseaux sociaux un sujet dames
sophie pélégry et de frédéric ciller
pour la rédaction de via occitanie sur
place
peu de personnes franchissent les portes
de cet hôtel particulier dans le centre
de la ville de beaucaire capitelles de
la terre d'argence dans le gard
construite au xviiie siècle parents
riches propriétaires et/ou les festives
dans les années 70
la demeure est aujourd'hui privé et
constituant des corps de rêve pour qui
voudrait se faire prendre en photo
on voit l'ambiance est là
toutes ces images seront postés sur
instagram je trouve que c'est sympa de
partager avec les gens qui nous suivent
nos découvertes qu'ils auraient
peut-être pas fait si nous suivait pas
donc je vois effectivement qui en a
certains qui vont où j'ai pu aller c'est
sympa parce qu'ils sont toujours
contents de découvertes qu'ils font
estelle est ce que l'on appelle une
influence euse comme toutes les
personnes présentes ici c'est instagram
heures qui cumulent un total de près de
140 mille abonnés et qui ce jour là vont
être amenées sur les hauts lieux
touristiques de la terre d'argence moi
j'ai deux mines abonnés sur instagram et
environ 300 et par poste et 700 vue
portoricaine sports extrêmes et dans le
voyage aussi
je
utiliser instagram pour attirer les
touristes sur beaucaire et ses alentours
cette unité de l'office de tourisme
beaucaire terre d'argence c'est un média
qui pour nous est très intéressant parce
qu'on se rend compte que avec quelques
influences heures on peut avoir une
portée qui est vraiment énorme on
n'était pas très fort sur instagram
jusqu'à présent et on est en train
d'investir ce nouveau média qui est très
porteur et aujourd'hui on peut plus s'en
passer une publicité à bas coûts car ces
influenceurs ne touchent aucune
rémunération
alors quel intérêt pour eux hormis une
visite au rester gratuite de participer
à ces journées un stamitz et mon pull
informe que je suis photographe et je
suis guide aussi alors ça aide les gens
qui me suis mis en garde ce que je fais
je découvre vif en région et 6e défense
pour ce coup de pub l'office de tourisme
a fait appel à une agence de
communication spécialisée dans les
réseaux sociaux et la création de
contenu transats géants à l'effigié du
territoire ou encore ces vieux combi
voyageurs devant lesquels lé instagram
heures peuvent se faire photographier
une manière de donner un air de vacances
et d' aventure au territoire
- souvent je vais utiliser des hashtag
généraux comme par exemple le hashtag
provence et regarder mais qu'est ce qui
pousse de jolies photos dans ce hashtag
voir si son compte est intéressant si la
personne est de la région et du coup
potentiellement l'invité par ce biais au
total 300 stories ont été publiées sur
les réseaux le jour même de la visite 50
de photos ont été postées et deux vidéos
est le moment
tout à fait autre chose dans le reste de
l'actualité nous nous rendons en
martinique où ils sont considérés comme
des nuisibles au même titre que les rats
toute l'année les agents de la ville de
fort de france mène des campagnes de
desigual nisation introduit dans les
années 60 la prolifération de l'iguane
menace aujourd'hui l'iguane endémique et
la biodiversité locale marie tricot et
johan boulard pour vyas atv sur place
christian prépare son lasso pour
atteindre la cime aucun volatile en vue
il part à la chasse d'un iguane le geste
doit être rapide
autant que cet envahisseur l'iguane
commun une espèce qui pullulent sur les
remparts du fort saint louis et
l'invasion se répand dans tous les
quartiers faut y aller vraiment y'a pas
de fête mix c'est comme avoir une bonne
can puis un bol à chaud et puis bon
voilà et puis c'est en approcher du csm
façon pour pouvoir le captif
cet iguane a été introduit en martinique
dans les années 60 il gagne aujourd'hui
du terrain sur son cousin endémiques de
l'île emna ce dernier d'autant que
l'iguane comme un peu farouche est
plutôt apprécié de ses observateurs
humains et ils pouvaient tout ce qu'il
faut comme nourriture des baux clavette
policiers en fonction de la nourriture
comme tout animal il ya des gens qui les
nourrissent en plus donc ça arrive comme
ici sur la savane il ya des gens qui
ramène des fruits donc ils sont toujours
là donc ça va vite la chasse est ouverte
chaque mardi priorité aux femelles qui
peuvent pondre jusqu'à 42 e minimum à
chaque gestation
comme ça de tout ça
c'est un baume à une formation a été
dispensée aux équipes par l'office
national des forêts et là des halles qui
l'est pèse et les mesures une fois
capturés la conclusion est fatale
l'animal est systématiquement mise à
mort par tir de carabine il important de
lutter contre les one commun parce qu'il
est et il est une menace pour les gones
endémique et quand je dis menace pour
les gones endémique c'est qu'une fois
qu'ils se reproduit avec l'iguane pays
est bonne et les jeunes sont peu à peu
du disque oui et prend le pas une
vingtaine de reptile a été attrapé ce
jour là en quelques heures à peine les
équipes de la ville profite de ses
tracks hebdomadaire pour rappeler qu'il
est interdit d'introduire ces iguane de
les détenir ou d'en faire commerce
comment apprendre à faire du feu filtrer
de l'eau ou exécuter les premiers gestes
de secours eh bien les stages de survie
se multiplient depuis quelques années en
france bien loin de l'image relayé ces
derniers temps dans l'actualité le
survivalisme a surtout pour objectif de
repousser les limites des participants
dans les vosges un week-end survivalisme
était organisée en forêt un week-end
auquel ont participé livia buchelay et
ludovic muzilla de la d'action de vosges
télévision regard des
[Musique]
exercices commando conditions une idée
une température ne dépassant pas les 12
degrés dans le secteur de la piquante
pierres sur les hauteurs de basse sur le
rupt les corps sont fatigués et c'est à
ce moment bien précis qu'il faut réussir
à repousser ses limites dans ce stage de
survivalisme une mouvance au coeur de
l'actualité il ya quelques semaines dans
notre département la petite mia était
enlevée par un réseau qui se
revendiquait survivalistes est associé à
l'extrême droite loin de l'état d'esprit
de ce professionnel on peut faire de la
survie sans pour autant avoir des idées
très très extrême d'un côté ou de
l'autre et sans effectivement sens on
peut faire plein de choses et le sur les
balises ça commence à partir du moment
où on apprend à vivre avec la nature
caraman apprendre à faire un peu
apprendre à filtrer l'eau les bases du
secourisme pour moi c'est le début du
survival ici on parle de dépassement de
soi où le mental représente 80% de la
réussite c'est six aventuriers de 18 à
43 ans sportifs ou non avait choisi de
consacrer leur week end dernier à ce
stage de survie c'est aussi pour savoir
où sont mes limites les repousser
toujours et je te redorer la survie
trouve qu'on est dans une époque où on
fait tout peut tellement bougé du jour
au lendemain que apprendre des gestes de
premiers secours ou au savoir the bruit
tout seul c'est vraiment quelque chose
de très pratique les deux journées
dirigé par des instructeurs qui endosse
un rôle d'où la cagoule sont rythmées
par diverses activités de défense
d'orientation de secourisme ou
d'exercices physiques entrecoupée d'une
nuit en bivouac mouvementée objectif
aller au bout et ne pas craquer
plusieurs fois on les a menés à leurs
limites et plusieurs fois ils les ont
franchi pour nous c'est aussi un jeu
parce que l'on se rend compte que s'ils
ont réussi à franchir une première fois
ils ont augmenté leur seuil de tolérance
et on les ramène on les ramène on les
ramène et à nous de savoir doser pour
nous arrêter au au bon moment des stages
qui ont le vent en poupe ces dernières
années si la télé réalité en pousse
certains à sauter le pas la crise
sanitaire pourrait elle aussi avoir un
impact sur ce succès qui visiblement
n'est pas près de s'arrêter ça dit que
les gens aient envie de revenir à la
nature après les différents confinement
il était en quarts mais ils ont
découvert plein de choses de même aussi
c'est une découverte de soi parce qu'ils
se connaissaient pas comme ça
une démarche d'ailleurs accessible même
pour les plus jeunes puisque des stages
sont organisés dès l'âge de 5 ans bien
loin donc de l'image extrémiste qui a pu
relayer l'actualité de ces derniers
temps
bien loin de la boue et de l'effort
physique maintenant déguster un verre de
vin relève du pur plaisir surtout en
plein été et à ce propos connaissez-vous
le vin vegan il s'agit d' à vincent un
tronc d'origine animale à l'intérieur si
vous ne le saviez pas vous risquez d'en
entendre parler pendant vos vacances
producteurs et commerçants se tournent
de plus en plus vers ce type de vin
comme a pu le constater à bordeaux
victor coup drop pour télé 7 la chaîne
du groupe sud ouest
elle domine le village de baume dans le
sud-gironde la propriété viticole
dirigée par vincent la bergère s'étend
sur 84 hectares ici vivent trois cépages
de vignes sémillon sauvignon et
muscadelle mais la vraie particularité
du vin produit sur ses terres se trouve
ailleurs normalement pour les vins
blancs on utilise de façon usuelle des
protéines d'origine animale qui sont
soit des cols de poisson soit de la
gélatine de porc également de la caséine
de l'est de façon à clarifier
naturellement et stabiliser les vins
c'est ce qu'ils utilisaient communément
ici au château de ravignan on a fait un
choix d'un travail différent sans ces
intrants qui vont nous permettre de
respecter cette norme de ne pas utiliser
de protéines d'origine animale un vin
vegan donc une tendance qui commence à
être un argument de poids dans les
négociations
dans ce bar à vin du centre-ville
bordelais on a choisi le château de
vincent la bergère justement pour ce vin
sans intrants d'origine animale
plus qu'une tendance ça va être aussi un
mouvement de fond de l'alimentation
végétale en général et la consommation
vegan parce que voilà on voit bien dans
les autres séries que ça se développe et
excellent prise de conscience est ici
toutes les bouteilles les tapas sont
certifiés 100 % vegan c'est d'ailleurs
le premier bar à vins de ce style en
france
et le vin décidément en pleine
révolution vous allez le voir près de
limoges toujours nouvelle équipe
tiennent une jeune entreprise bio phytos
réinvente l'aja en céramique cette
matière remplace donc le bois ou l'inox
pour la conservation et la maturation du
vin la céramique permet notamment de ne
pas colorer le vin ni de modifier son
bout depuis le mois de septembre dernier
un commercial a rejoint l'équipe
céramique de bio phytos preuve de son
succès un succès est racontée par alain
dru et de la rédaction de cet animal sur
place
après un passage à l'incubateur est un
démarrage à esther l'entreprise bio
pitot se fait le choix de s'installer à
la campagne précisément à bonnac la côte
à quelques minutes de l'autoroute a20
aujourd'hui l'entreprise est en phase de
croissance avec une
complète de contenants céramiques et
porcelaines pour les vins et les
spiritueux
donc là on a la jarre équipe est telle
qu'on pourrait la voir chez le
viticulteur c'est ça exactement donc
le couvercle avec système de fermeture
pour venir verrouillé et puis une bombe
sceptique envers le niveau de vin va
monter ou descendre en fonction des
fluctuations de température de
dilatation du vin et puis un petit
réservoir qui permet d'inertes est en
fait le le contenant de façon ce qui est
pas de data qu'on va dire de l'oxygène
clique qui pourrait venir transformer le
vin au vinaigre il a fallu avoir
quelques bases effectivement sur la
viticulture pour ne serait-ce que
communiquer un peu avec les clients pour
essayer aussi un peu de les aiguiller
les orienter sur le choix du contenant
positionné entre la céramique et la
viticulture fanny doit exprimer le plus
produit de biopic hausse face aux
professionnels d'ubs pour plusieurs
points a déjà les inertes c'est-à-dire
qu'elles n'apportent aucun à rome on a
différents on a différentes critiques de
cuisson température de cuisson donc on
va pouvoir avoir différentes
perméabilité et jouer là dessus donc
avoir une dynamique roxy nations
différentes donc plus ou moins
importante en fonction du vin que l'on
souhaite faire la vigne est dedans et
pendant ce temps la recherche et
développement se poursuivent donc on
travaille sur différents procédés
alternatifs pour gagner en productivité
pour gagner en
coups et également pour une meilleure
maîtrise de ces éléments là donc on a
par exemple ce procédé de calibrage en
fait mais avec l'apport d'un robot voie
qui permet d'automatiser et puis de
d'aller plus loin sur la fabrication de
pièces notamment au niveau de la taille
au niveau des formes et puis les
techniques d'impression addictives c'est
ça on travaille sur ces techniques de
pression 3 des voix ça reste encore en
développement mais ça peut être pour
nous un élément
de productivité de flexibilité qui sont
importants
comme chaque semaine le grand jt des
territoires vous propose des idées de
lecture pour l'été aujourd'hui nous
sommes en duplex avec denis dupuis
bonjour denis dupuis vous êtes
chirurgien est l'auteur d'un roman qui
vient de paraître c'est votre troisième
ouvrage il s'appelle le bien le mal est
l'ordinaire pouvez vous nous présenter
son troupes en dévoiler la trame cet
ouvrage qui se déroule à toulouse
il ya d'abord eu morphine bistouri et
autres emmerdements édition le faucon
d'or qui retraçait la biographie d'un
chirurgien toxicomanes à sa jeunesse et
son son long combat pour se défaire de
ses addictions le second tumulte et
submersion aux éditions des presses
littéraires se pencher sur l'existence
de ces chirurgiens des décennies plus
tard largement défait de sa dépendance
est donc le troisième reprend le
personnage du docteur 33 il croise
camomille qui est un infirmier
trentenaire affligé par une toxicomanie
très inquiétante un jeune homme à la
dérive qui le prend sous son aile en
espérant les des données du puits une
nouvelle fois le lieu d'action est une
clinique alors à travers votre roman
souhaitez vous raconter l'envers du
décor d'un monde médical que l'on
reconnaît trop peu il est exact que dans
mon second roman j'ai dressé quelques
caricatures quelques portraits peu
flatteurs mon regard il se porte plutôt
sur l'humain et en particulier sur
l'humain en souffrance confrontés à la
maladie dans cette optique je reprends
le personnage de monsieur bel abbès qui
est un vieux monsieur algériens immigrés
que je soigne depuis des années et qui
est affligée par un épouvantable cancer
à l'issue inéluctable
je préfère me pencher sur ces
souffrances et y réfléchir que donner
des leçons à des confrères que je
respecte et que je ne surclasse
aucunement
l'actualité plus précisément lakovic 19
sont elles des sources d'inspiration
pour vous
elle est tapi dans mon roman prête à
jaillir parce que j'écris au
commencement de l'épidémie donc le
docteur 33 se questionnent quant à la
réalité de l'épidémie sa réalité
médicale et scientifique
sans pathos ni émotion puisque
évidemment il n'a pas à nier la réalité
de cette épidémie il se questionne sur
les décisions sur la rationalité des
décisions d'un pouvoir pour qu'il n'a
pas beaucoup de sympathie alors le
pouvoir c'est le pouvoir en général le
docteur 33 revendique une autonomie
de pensée
et il n'a pas de parti il est aussi
question de problématiques métaphysique
dans ce roman oui la métaphysique la
barca caron la fameuse
elle aussi est en filigrane dans mes
écrits
l'auteur changes alors que les ans
égrène que tout cela va prendre ça et
ils se demandent à quoi rime la
mascarade vers quoi se meut la lugubre
procession de cadavres aux en devenir où
mène le voyage sur quoi la vie s'ouvre
telle ba elle s'ouvre sur de l'humour en
réalité un dans mon ouvrage en tout cas
et l'humour on le comprend transpire
dans ce nouvel ouvrage merci denis
dupuis vous êtes je le rappelle l'auteur
d'un troisième robin le bien le mal est
l'ordinaire aux éditions annickjubien
elle était à vous sans transition du
vélo dans ce grand jt des territoires
rien à voir avec le tour de france qui
s'est achevée il ya quelques jours du
vélo pour arpenter les territoires et
faire du tourisme c'est l'idée originale
d'une guide touristique de la loire une
autre façon de découvrir les plus beaux
spots de la région adrien bletterie la
rédaction de thé n 7 a testé tourisme à
vélo regardez
du ciel bleu du soleil et un peu
d'effort physique que demander de plus
tout au long de l'année stéphanie fait
découvrir sa région avec des itinéraires
différents l'un d'entre eux traversent
la commune de cottance pour raconter
l'histoire du tissage on voit notamment
la partie la plus courte la qui est
généralement orientées au nord ce qui
permettait de laisser passer la lumière
le tissage il fallait vraiment avoir
beaucoup de lumière pour moi la
précision depuis deux ans l'office du
tourisme de forêt est utilisent des
vélos électriques pour faire découvrir
le patrimoine ligérien
est là on résiste on s'est dit on
voulait peut-être toucher une autre
clientèle voilà amener un petit peu des
personnes qui voulaient découvrir le
patrimoine autrement et ça s'est
vraiment développée donc cette année par
rapport à la crise sanitaire on s'est
dit qu'il fallait qu'on fasse beaucoup
de visites en extérieur du coup on a
multiplié sa visite à vélo la balade des
se fait uniquement sur route le but est
de découvrir et d'explorer mais sans
prendre de risques
j'ai ma collègue jessica qui est
derrière et qui ferme la marche là haut
niveau sécurité il ya pas qu on veut
essayer de faire cette année s'est
développée plus des des animations pour
les familles en extérieur donc là nous
sommes en train de travailler sur une
animation sur le site de donzy qui un
peu plus loin salt en donzy
pour les familles avec les enfants et en
utilisant les technologies modernes dont
notamment avec une application sur
smartphone stéphanie a quand même la
chance de pouvoir toujours exercé son
métier et depuis les deux confinement
les ligériens ont aussi envie de plus
sortir au lieu d'une visite par semaine
la guide a triplé j'espère qu'elle va
pas trop durer parce que tous les guides
qui font des visites l'intérieur c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué où on a la
chance du coup de pouvoir développer des
nouvelles thématiques on a fait la
visite trois fois dans la semaine
puisqu'on a eu la demande donc du coup
on a proposé trois fois et si le vélo
peut remplacer les bâtons de randonnée
les balades à pied existe toujours 110
circuit en boucle existe dans 42
communes différentes dans l'est du
département
et maintenant des tableaux connus dans
le monde entier exposées dans les
yvelines la joconde marylène ou encore
napoléon bonaparte
ces tableaux de maîtres sont à découvrir
actuellement au château de croatie
particularité de cette tableau ils sont
en lego une exposition originale donc
pour parcourir les périodes emblématique
de la peinture française et sur des
terres impressionniste reportage de tv
78 la chaîne des îles glénan regarder
une exposition de tableaux de grands
maîtres entièrement construit en briques
lego c'est l'exposition qui est
actuellement proposée au château chan
aurier à croissy sur seine c'est une
exposition sur les tableaux de maîtres
voilà donc c'est vraiment une exposition
où les gens vont pouvoir s'asseoir
étudier des tableaux et regarder des
tableaux comme dans un vrai musée quoi
sur place pas de surprise la plupart des
oeuvres présentées sont des tableaux
bien connu alors dans cette exposition
vous avez une trentaine de tableaux donc
en bas vous avez plus le classique
l'impressionnisme bien sûr puisqu'on est
à croissy vous allez retrouver le
tableau de renoir est au dessus à
l'étagé du dessus vous allez retrouver
un petit peu plus de modernité avec le
pop art notamment et andy warhol
[Musique]
toutes les oeuvres ont été réalisées à
croissy l'exposition a représenté 1200
heures de travail et sept cent quarante
mille briques à côté de chaque toile
vous avez un cartel qui explique
l'oeuvre et le nombre de briques lego
utilisé pour l'oeuvre et puis le temps
passé pour la montrer un parcours de jeu
est prévu pour les enfants l'exposition
est proposée jusqu'au 18 juillet mais
attention la réservation est obligatoire
pour pouvoir venir visiter voilà pour
finir ce journal partons à la découverte
d'un produits de nos terroirs
le fromage de calenzana en corse un
savoir faire ancestral à base de lait de
brebis ou de chèvre d'ailleurs très
appréciée localement et on comprend
pourquoi avec ces images qui nous donne
l'eau à la bouche
ce propos écouter une bergère
productrice de ce fromage
caractéristiques de l'île de beauté
dévoile quelques secrets de fabrication
au micro de la rédaction devient telle
est pas aisé sandrine guidoni
c'est un fromage pis tant il a affiné
dans les grandes caisses en bois qui
font de mètres sur un mètre mais 600 à
700 fromage à l'intérieur qu'on lave une
fois par semaine pendant de six mois à 8
mois ça dépend de l'intensité de piquant
qu'on veut du fromage frais on mène dans
des gouttières qui le font kg rendre car
et on le sale trois fois une fois qu'ils
soient un peu de bus relais mais en
caisse ou les meilleurs chiens que ce
qui fait un bon fromage c'est le
l'endroit où les chèvres sont elles
mangent pas la même chose des herbes
peut-être pas les mêmes saveurs pour le
lait puis chacun utilise une sorte de
prise sur différentes enfin il ya un tas
de petits détails qui fait que le
fromage est différent
voilà bon fromage corse qui donne envie
de passer à table c'est la fin de ce
grand jt des territoires merci de
l'avoir suivi sur vos chaînes locales de
la tnt et sur tv5 monde on se retrouve
très vite pour un tour complet de
l'actualité au revoir à tous et bon
courage
[Musique]